hey there boys and girls welcome back to
new rockstars I'm Sam basher here with
yet another MCU rewatch breakdown we're
currently making our way through the
2014 releases of my personal favorite MC
movies came out in that you're
specifically guardians of the galaxy you
guys know the drill here's a spoiler
warning for guardians galaxies 1 & 2 of
the MCU gardens galaxy comics this is
spoiler warning yours gonna be spoilers
what do you want that's one how it works
anyways let's kick it off with comic
book Easter eggs my favorite cuz I'm a
nerd
let's kick it off with guardians of the
galaxy as a whole when did they Day
people
well yes silly gooses they debuted in
Marvel superheroes number 18 in January
1969 now originally they were a team
from the future specifically the 31st
century and they did include one
character from this movie specifically
yondu but he's very different don't
worry I'll get into him a little later
in this video so let's kick it off with
star-lord he first debuted in Marvel
preview number four in January 1979 he
ended up kind of being sidelined as this
like side character they saw out in
space every once in a while as a part of
Marvel's cosmic line of characters but
eventually he got revamped in 2004 to
the character that we know now they're
moving forward again we see Morag a
planet that seems to be housing and
protecting the orb that's also housing
one of the Infinity stones and getting
ahead of myself but Morag isn't actually
a planet within the Marvel Comics
universe or multiverse is actually just
a random planet created for this movie
but the name Morag is a tribute to one
of the first Korean leaders in the
comics how fun I didn't want to point
out the star Lords mask is pretty
similar to the more revamped style of
his helmet in the comics I also want to
point out that in the movie Peters guns
are more just like blasters I got like
two little barrels on the top and bottom
of them but originally in the comics
they are actually called element guns
meaning they can control the elements
they can you know control rocks or
lightning or you know freeze stuff that
kind of thing and during this opening
scene when he's dancing a lot of people
online point out this skeleton right
here with the kind of horse face might
be a korbinite which korbinite is the
race of beta ray bill beta ray bill
here's a character from the comics that
gets a Thor hammer
it's called storm breaker and we always
wanted him pop up in the Thor movies but
that never really happened also worth
pointing out that we see the Power Stone
for the very first time in the MCU which
is inside the orbits the MacGuffin of
the movie I do want to point out that
the henchmen type aliens that are
bang out Ronin and his cronies are Sekar
ins orsic Aryans however you'd like to
say it now we do know what Sekar is now
in the MCU it's actually like one of
these set pieces for thor ragnarok but
originally in the comics a car is a
planet that the Hulk gets sent to in a
form of exile he ends up being the ruler
of it also wanted to point out that we
see a troll doll a number of times in
this movie originally appearing in this
opening scene we see the giant cassette
you know display inside of Peters ship
the Milano a lot of people have said
that this troll is a nod to pip the
troll from the comics who is a character
that has a lot of dealings with Thanos
and the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
which is the basis of the Infinity you
know war movie that's coming out soon
but our main villain of the film is part
of the Kree now who are the Kree well
originally they premiered in Fantastic
Four number 65 in August of 1967
they're one of the most popular alien
races in Marvel Comics now let's talk
about one of the other villains from the
movie yondu now in the comics he
originally appeared in Marvel heroes
number 18 in January 1969 now originally
in the comics he's not Kree but
eventually in volume 2 he's established
as being Kree originally he's from
Centauri for sure I'm saying that right
and he is the last of his race now in
the comics he does have blue skin and he
does have a red fin which we actually
see a more comic accurate one in volume
2 where we get a little nod to it with
me like shaved down form of the fin in
volume 1 also he does have an arrow in
the comics but normally has a bow that
goes along with and he just fires it
conventionally but he does have a
whistling technique that allows the
arrow to change directions midair also
worth pointing out that the Ravagers
yondu's team of pirates have the same
logo for the guardians of the galaxy
that they have in the comics if you see
that little badge looks like a flame a
little bit that is the audience of the
galaxy official symbol also worth
pointing out that the dark aster ronan
ship was an original creation for the
movie and it is awesome but speaking of
ronan he originally appeared in
Fantastic Four number 65 in August of
1967 now he is usually a villain but
sometimes he's more of like a noble
warrior who always defends the Kree no
matter what and there is some auditor
that makes him a far more interesting
character than just murder burger
everywhere you dub me in the galaxy also
his costume is very similar to the comic
book costume
oh my god I'm already sweaty keeping it
going with the villains we also meet
nebula for the first time in the MCU now
she first appeared in Avengers number
257 in July of nineteen
85 now originally instead of being the
adoptive daughter or whatever daughter
of Thanos in the MCU she was the
granddaughter of Thanos in the comics
and she plays a huge role in the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline again when I
said the basis for the infinity war
movie pretty cool that also brings us to
Gamora who first appeared in strange
tales number 180 in June of 1975 now her
family was killed by religious
extremists on her planet and she was
kind of rescued and were brought in by
Thanos and was raised to be the
deadliest woman in the galaxy I'm doing
air quotes cuz that's the term they
actually use in the comics and she is
cybernetically enhanced in the comics as
well
now nebula Gamora aren't really sisters
in the comics but that is a very
interesting take to add to the MCU I
think it adds a lot speaking of alien
worlds let's talk about Xand are the
home of the Nova Corps now this planet
first appeared in Nova number one in
September 1976 and this brings us to
Rocket Raccoon hooray
he first appeared in Marvel preview
number seven in June of 1976 now
originally he's from the planet half
world where animals are experimented on
and enhanced biologically and with some
techne actually see some of the tech
implants when rocket is you know
shirtless and after taking a shower in
the kiln the kilns very important the
comics too I'll come back to that in a
second but let's talk about Groot our
favorite group he first appeared in
tales to astonish number 13 originally
just a tree based one note villain in
the comics it wasn't really until the
2000s when he was reimagined as a hero
also I wanted to explain why he only
says I am Groot because in the comics
it's explained that his language is so
difficult to understand because his
larynx is stiff because it's made out of
wood but that's why it sounds like I am
Groot he's actually saying more things I
am Groot is more complex than that
but only a few people can understand it
all so that brings us to the Nova Corps
they are very different from the comics
for the most part the symbol is pretty
similar to the Nova symbol that is in
the comics but they first appeared in
Fantastic Four number 205 and April of
1979 and basically their spacecrafts now
let's get to the lineup scene there are
a couple fun Easter eggs here but let's
focus on the good ones like when Gamora
shows up we see that she's a part of the
Z oh they're re people which is a nod to
her race in the comics I just had to
sound it out this in Wales and get
through that word also when it gets to
rocket we see a half world mention the
plant where he comes from also the name
Lila which is an acquaintance so
significant other sometimes in the
comics to rocket let's move on to the
kiln the prison that the guardians are
sent to this is a prison in the comics
but it looks significantly different as
kind of orbs all put together it's also
a power plant but it's like the prison
you can't break out up I guess who
breaks out of it
I mean characters because they have to
do the rest of the movie but moving
forward let's talk about Drax the
destroyer the final guardian member to
join the group hooray now in the comics
Ridge '''l II he is not an alien he was
a human on earth whose family is killed
by Thanos but then cosmic beings take
Arthur Douglas his soul put it in a more
powerful body and he becomes Drax the
destroyer his main purpose in life is to
destroy Thanos you kids cheering also of
course I gotta mention he first appeared
in Iron Man number 55 in February of
1973 then moving forward to the fan of
scene with Ronan this place is called
the sanctuary where Thanos seems to be
hiding out but in the comics sanctuary
is actually the name of Thanos ship his
scheme chin forward we meet tan Illya -
van - von however you want to say it he
first appeared in the post-credits scene
for Thor the dark world aka the
collector he first appeared in Avengers
number 28 in May of 1966 he is an elder
of the universe someone who's been there
forever and he collects things but
moving forward to the collection for the
collector we meet Cosmo the space dog
and we actually had a fun nod to rocket
& Kosmos relationship in the comics yes
they have a relationship because he's a
telepathic dog not just that he's a
telepathic Russian dog yes he was a
Russian test subject for spaceflight and
eventually ended up in nowhere and he
became the head of security for this
giant head but he first appeared in Nova
vol 4 number 8 in January of 2008 Wow
he's a brand-new Lee boy also during the
final fights and after we lose GRU we
get the name drop for guardians of the
galaxy ronan gave him the name that's
amazing yay we didn't get a couple
post-credit scenes but the one I want to
focus on is the final one where we see
Cosmo is now free hopefully that means
that he's now going to be in charge of
nowhere maybe the security force which
would be pretty cool but hey can't wear
them all and I want to mention Howard
the Duck he's free a lot of people were
disappointed with this post-credit scene
because in need
to anything in the next Avengers movie
but after a while you kind of grow to
appreciate it now Howard the Duck
originally appeared in adventures in to
fear number 19 in December of 1973 and
he's like the original Deadpool he's a
duck from another universe but he got
pulled over to ours and he gets on wacky
adventures but like Deadpool he can
break the fourth wall and kind of talk
to the audience he's aware that he's in
a comic and his 80s film is great but
enough with the comic book Easter eggs
let's move it to the MCU Easter eggs
like Peter Quill's Mama's very sad that
she dies in this movie but this is the
same actor if we stop before in another
MCU movie this actresses Laura haddock
and she had a very small role as a woman
wanting to get an autograph from Captain
America then moving forward to our
meeting between Ronan and Thanos once
again we meet the other an original
creation for the MCU that first appeared
in Avengers but oh he's not coming back
they're moving forward to when we meet
the collector and his assistant Karina
or Karina Karina however he says it
Karina is actually from the comics and
she did appear in the Thor the dark
world post-credits scene I did talk
about it a little bit in that video but
I will mention that in the comics
originally she's the collectors doctor
also during this collector scene I did
want to point out a few fun Easter eggs
I was able to find like right here over
there it's kind of hard to see but that
is a Chitauri the villains from the
Avengers films are the one who invaded
New York and then I'll died for some
reason at the same time also if you
notice on the ground kind of land in a
very uncomfortable position you'll
notice it's a dark elf who did appear in
Thor the dark world I know about this
specific one but it's the same makeup
and same costume so hey fun little nod
also from the Thor the dark world
post-credits scene we see Adam warlocks
cocoon it's not the real one after
volume 2 of guardians of galaxy this
kind of Nix that but originally we all
thought that that was an amorous cocoon
just worth pointing out there moving
forward to a nebula is chasing down
Gamora right before she blows up her
ship you'll notice that she says of all
of our siblings during this movie I was
wondering who are the other siblings of
four at nebula and Gamora and now we
know for inventions infinity world we're
just going to meet all of them they are
the Black Order now I know on this
channel we're going to be doing a full
breakdown for the Black Order give me
the quick rundown of who these people
would be Corvus glaive Proxima midnight
evany mah and black dwarf I think those
are all of them and it's also we get to
pay off that one line from guardians of
the galaxy that one off line then moving
forward to the Guardians planning their
assault on the dark aster and you know
defeating
you hear that Peter Coyle has 12 percent
of a plan and I feel like this is a nod
to the 12 percent joke from Avengers
like check out this Dark Tower is your
baby
give yourself 12 percent its credit 12
percent also want to point out that the
gift that Peter gets from his mom when
he finally opens it it's a very fun nod
two Guardians the galaxy getting a green
light for another sequel I think it's
very sweet and I love that they actually
use that branding for the cassette and
the soundtrack you get for this movie
right it's pretty cool then moving
forward to our first post-credits scene
group dancing and then hiding from
Jack's freezing pretty fun joke that's
actually James Gunn in mocap that's his
little dance moves how fun is that and
finally guys I want to point out a
couple pop-culture references real quick
because kind of like doing that now
first up we get our marvel 2.0 logo I'm
a big fan of this one also moving
forward if you notice when Peter quill
lands on Morag he's using some sort of
scanner he's banging on it he's using it
to scan past offense that have happened
on this planet it's a very questionable
thing that he's using I couldn't figure
out what it was from a comic standpoint
but I did want to point out that that
little girl playing with a dog that dog
is James Gunn's dog in real life how
cool is that they moving forward to when
they are in the kiln you hear Peter
quill bring up Ark of the Covenant which
is kind of funny because because his
character kind of feels like a
reflection of Indiana Jones and this
whole thing was taken the orb out of its
little prison kind of feels like a nod
to Raiders a little bit also worth
pointing out that in the comics Peter
Quill's ship doesn't have a name
originally now it has a name which is
the Milano like it wasn't a movie but in
this movie it was because Peter quill
was supposed to have had a big crush on
Alyssa Milano when he was living on
earth that's why I named a ship Milano
pretty fun then when they're on nowhere
you hear references to Billy the Kid
Bonnie and Clyde John Stamos all famous
outlaws of course as well as you hear
Footloose get a fun mention as well as
Kevin Bacon Kevin Bacon also played a
Marvel character in x-men first class
also fun pop culture reference in the
collection you actually see a creature
from one of James Gunn's previous films
slither this slither will monsters well
slither slugs they're in one of the
cages in the background pretty cool also
I love the scooby-doo effect when Gamora
gets electrocuted and you see her bones
show up that's not how it works kids
just want to point that out they're
moving forward to when we find out what
was actually in the orb that was given
to yondu it's with the troll doll why
because Peter quill
old hymn also finally I wanted to point
out that when the guardians are leaving
Xander you noticed the three sons of
zand are kind of look like Mickey's head
it's not the sizes aren't right but
they're in the configuration of his ears
and his head because this was like the
first like Disney led original property
for Marvel Studios guardians of galaxies
okay go oh and of course how can I
freaking forget the Stan Lee cameo he's
very early on he's one of those and
Aryans that Rockets you know trying to
pique bond to see if he's you know
wealthy maybe they'll steal from them
who knows but hey that's the Cameo oh
wow okay guys we made it those are all
of the Easter eggs for Marvel Comics in
the MCU and pop-culture references that
I could find
dear Lord James kind of team did a great
job hiding a bunch of them but let me
know what your favorites were in the
comments down below or on twitter at
only stupid answers ink out the bells
from stupid that's the twitter i've been
trying to use more often but make sure
you like this video share it with your
friends who enjoy the guardians of
galaxy movies and subscribe for more
content again like I said there's gonna
be a breakdown on the black order on
this channel eventually there's a
breakdown on Thanos that should be going
up very soon if not up already and also
check out my other MCU re-watch videos
but again I'm Sam back here and I'll see
you next time